c'est l'adhérence que j'ai perdu j'ai le
temps de freiner à peine le temps de
mettre le frein à main que j'ai tout
appris dans le truc de la remorque mais
j'ai rien pu faire quoi
la neige ça fait glisser comme le soleil
fait bronzer voici donc quelques
conseils si vous devez prendre la route
et quelques points les plus importants
c'est essayer de
d'effleurer la de frein voilà de
l'utiliser mais vraiment avec prudence
d'utiliser beaucoup le frein moteur
juste en lâchant d'accélérateur pour
ralentir et donc d'anticiper justement
toutes ces situations là est de faire le
plus tôt possible donc lâcher
l'accélérateur le plus tôt possible une
moins bonne visibilité un conte est un
véhicule comme ça devant d'accord du
coup tu vois pas à travers les vitres si
les véhicules de devant fresnes
d'accord ça peut créer du coup un
problème d'anticipation donc du coup
c'est bien on augmente les espaces de
sécurité c'est parfait car le risque en
cas de freinage trop fort c'est la perte
d'adhérence dans ce cas là tout de suite
coupé l'accélérateur pour retrouver de
la motricité et était de continuer la
perte d'adhérence ne surtout pas écraser
la de frein
c'est souvent ce que les gens font ils
ont peur dont il a appuyé sur le frein
très fort mais ça va augmenter ce qui
enfin se passer
il faut aussi rouler en sous-régime
plutôt qu en surrégime et contrebraquer
si le véhicule chasse de l'ariège mais
la théorie ne fait pas forcément
disparaître l'appréhension
j'ai peur que ça que les rouvrir que ça
j'ai perdu lycée faut pas trop freiner
je reste prudent j'habite verdien j'ai à
peu près une heure de route
vous avez un peu d'appréhension pour
repartir sur je vais rouler doucement
oui c'est sûr de faire attention aux
distances de sécurité sur tout météo
france prévoit encore quelques chutes de
neige sur l'ensemble de la région pour
la nuit
vivement l'été et ses terrasses
ensoleillées